movement that has spread across our
great nation and we are marching this
movement straight towards election 2020
where we that will choose the next
president of the United States of
America
[Applause]
we talk to a lot of candidates this time
but the questions that you're going to
hear will come directly from our members
these are imitators who have submitted
their questions through our website on
the eve of a video or targeting it in
and in asking what they want to hear
strong public schools org anyone can go
out there and look
jewelry's a firm each caning and this is
important because of their teachers we
know when to tell them they're going to
close down right we are going to each of
these candidates ten minutes let me tell
you how it's going to go you will have
if you candidate one minute of an
opening remark anything they want to say
then they will answer three questions
one will be on a video the other two
will be written we've taken them right
off the website the candidates will have
no more than three minutes to answer
each question you can take a look in the
corner of the screen we're going to put
it up there I think when they start
talking you'll see
[Applause]
you know when it gets to zero and it
counts down I didn't want to like to cut
off my so give him a gun or a buzz or
you know like sold them that'd be fun
but no no how do you want to do because
we're play is when it says zero we will
start applauding nobody gives more time
than someone else maybe some ability'
candidate for us could learn how to be
polite and we're for us 21 beginning
just right right now may I introduce to
you our first candidate who would like
to be the next president of the United
States
please welcome Bernie Sanders
[Applause]
I see this big papaya variance to make
I am wearing this high proudly today to
congratulate the NEA and teachers all
over this country who have the courage
to march on the landscape happen to the
made me change the national priorities
in this country that instead of giving
factories to the billionaires and
subsidies to the fossil fuel industry
that we invest in the children of this
country and education
that at the verge of the teachers is
reverberating all over this country
working people from coast to coast
ah now the demanding and economy that
works for all of us
the mascots of the 1% teachers thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
to me
so what we did is we put together a
focus that I had called the defending
Social Security caucus and we said that
we will not allow Social Security
retirement age to the Grays we will not
support a so-called chain CPI that will
be all about is not cutting Social
Security is expanding Social Security
Baptist
legislation that I proposed was called
scrapping the dekat right now in America
if you hang up about 130,000 a year you
pay the same amount into the Social
Security as somebody who makes thirty
thousand your ability millionaire you
only be paying Social Security taxes on
the first a hundred and thirty thousands
of hours that seems to be to be absurd
so our legislation does is lift that cap
on he will make 250,000 or more but the
top 1% we bring his substantial sums of
revenue which losing's
expands Social Security benefits for
low-income seniors and second the walk
it extends the life of Social Security
by about 50 years
now all of you know that it was a little
anís 45 years that has been a war of
against the working class all the
country and at the same time where
Republicans want to give back traits to
billionaires they have talking about
putting Social Security Medicare and
Medicaid
we are believed to stand up to the net
and our view is if you're not gonna cut
Social Security if you're better extend
the like minute so that it will be
strong and viable crop kids and our
grandchildren give it a knock gonna cut
banana path because we're going to go
fight for a Medicare for All
single-payer program
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
really by those two tasks again you can
ask for the video our first minute video
question comes from Ariel be in Hawaii
[Applause]
how are you going to do anybody salaries
to make teaching more attractive so that
we have less teachers or Indonesian
why'd they make so much very and the
truth is the innocence beyond teachers
the insula has everything to do with GG
national priorities we're changing the
culture of America so that we recognize
that there is nothing more important
than in America
[Applause]
and we appreciate that education and
learning is all about the human life has
to do it actually be learning for the
daily one - the day we die and of course
in America the wealthiest country in the
history of the world it must go without
saying we are going to have the best
public schools in the entire world
[Applause]
and that means that they imposed without
saying that we are going to have
teachers who receive the respects and
the proliferation that they deserve for
doing some of the most important work in
America
[Applause]
and it means that when we talk about
features in the years 2019 but what
money proposal but I have worked for
comprehensive proposal on education says
that every teacher in America
to earn at least six apology
[Applause]
it also another proposal that you
brought blue impacts 45 million
Americans including many teachers is
that it is absurd ha ha funny about
people struggling with the process of
the levels of saluting death we
[Applause]
and I think RIT assigns the district
repulsive I'm criticized for having
proposal because I'm trying to stand up
working families in this country and not
the billionaire class proposal if we
could have the crooks on Wall Street to
the tune of friends about it we surely
[Applause]
from Linda a teacher in having how will
you strengthen our country's public
schools and TANF citizens of the think
about why privatization church schools
are not good for our children
[Applause]
well for influence please go to my
website and if you do but this is what
you will find
I love proposal called the third debacle
of the plan we end the federal funding
completely before
[Applause]
taxpayer money should be going to
entertain our kids not to make Wall
Street investors even richer
[Applause]
and our proposal puts a moratorium on
all the new particles who you have a
full understanding of their impact on
public education
[Applause]
and our proposal not only triples
funding for title one proposal not only
moves on aggressively
you
in another area raises the federal
minimum wage to $15 an hour
[Applause]
how the proposal moves aggressively to
the end the increased segregation that
we've seen in schools in this country
our proposal under the sense that real
education devotion to us and at the end
of the school day we need to
significantly increase funding for after
the school programs
we need to make cooler and in our
country when kids leave school at the
end of the school year they were is 10
what they have learned is to the fool
which is why he saw the programs
and our proposal also saying that it's
not trust educated if we have got to end
the disgrace of hanging the highest rate
of childhood poverty of any major
country on earth
[Applause]
[Applause]
catcher
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh
one minute to tell us anything you want
us to know about and when the captain I
could just assume we're going to thank
you very much
man Thank You Louise
we're on a stroll I would say how much I
appreciate the opportunity to be with
you here today
say how much I appreciate all of the
educators who are here who helped pave
the dreams of so many of Americans come
true I come to you here today with a
vision for the future of our country and
then in the 21st century of an America
he has a smartest that the hunkiest that
the parents that the most prosperous
nation on earth I come here as the proud
product of the public schools of San
Antonio
[Applause]
the son of a father who was a public
school educator for 31 years and the
husband of a lion we've been a public
school educator from 15
[Applause]
it's going to be the smartest nation in
the 21st century we need you thank you
for having me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the San Antonio independent and Andrew
an independent school district that
never were two of the poorest public
school districts in the state and so I
know from firsthand experience he
impacted rolling around in segregated
school districts my high school was
probably 80 or 85 percent
mexican-american but the challenge is
that the challenges today we're still
grappling with so many issues that we
were roughly with 30 40 50 years ago and
our educators who tremendous job where
their students you'll all see in
everyday the impact of that segregation
what are we gonna do about it
a few weeks ago I released what I call
my people preferred education plan and
one of the purpose of that deals with
preparedness and education we want to
make sure that every child giving again
has remained an education is possible in
an addition to in in audacity and our
educators is in treating them with
respect and coming at me when it comes
to that improving public education and
in addition of investing in the
facilities and opportunity we need also
to do things like tackle housing
segregation when I was Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development under
President Obama we have schools
groundbreaking rule called affirming the
improving fair housing
it was the most groundbreaking leads to
fair housing act to further desegregate
our country I would also in audacity
were housing in our community in high
opportunity areas so they have students
ability to go and initially they
couldn't afford to year and in addition
to that
and invest in tools like voluntary
busing so the Denzil the district's most
really devoted different tools and I
would make sure that we advanced in fair
housing imprisonment because for all the
times when a family of Connor grows they
they look for on a curtain of our house
in certain neighborhoods they're still
turned down simply because of the color
of their skin when we need to do all of
those things and we're gonna tackle the
continuous segregation is 12 times the
limit the ability of our schemes to
achieve their aims
[Applause]
[Music]
we have women question for sympathy
who's a seminary teacher from Alaska he
asked my name is about down the last two
years due to rising cost of health
insurance what I really do to address
this problem
thank you very much for the question
I believe that there is no reason in our
country that anybody should ever go
without health insurance because I grew
up I grew up with a grandmother we would
come to the United States and years old
Franco
whenever little significant returns and
I and their closest relatives she grew
up on the west side the same people you
know doesn't hated equipment in
elementary school remains my mom is
ignorant and then my mom raised by my
brother using her my grandmother for as
long as I knew her life to my knees and
I was just you know not worse and worse
that's when she had to have gonna be
amputated
which is many quotes the audience to
know is he's very common for some serial
diabetics but the voltage at Medicare I
want to surrender the Medicare for the
books provide it and then make sure the
net occurs again
everyone loves it in this country
because oftentimes I believe that the
difference between health care and in
health insurance it is it health
insurance is the denial letter but you
can't tell either the two of the reasons
why you're not going to get covered or
you are covered but the out-of-pocket
expenses the constitutional to rate we
can change and improve of our system I
also believe that either fundamentally
transform our healthcare system for the
new city one of the powerful things for
instance we need to end the distinction
between visible health care and mental
health care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and as admissible educators you see the
impact that our health care system and
shortcomings have on our students each
and every day my education behind mostly
in the best scene and in a community
school based model it includes without
maybe luckier I believe that all of
these things go together that all of
these Doc's are negative we don't exist
we don't live in silos and neither
should our policy in this country
[Applause]
[Music]
secretary Castro maybe kind of some
Jay's in Illinois how do you propose to
allow professional anticipate it in the
formation of true education reform with
the help of the one that goes to this
question in between Public Law so I went
back to my old high school
I just put money to look like an 18 long
as a school I got really classic women
is 51 and 37 which I thought was against
Texas law and apparently not on the
third day that I was there I turned
around to write something on the
blackboard and it's something from the
back of the room like together like
loosely pages and shoved into the back
of my head meet me in the back of my
head and I didn't know what to do I
didn't know whether to turn around and
done it trying send them to the vice
principal's office or to pretend like it
didn't happen save my dignity I remember
every single day going home
now
[Applause]
remember the joy of the moments when I
felt like I never really helped the
super understand something understand
before and the registration what I felt
like I wasn't groove or that I could see
they needed other resources or they
needed something else that I wasn't able
to give I think anyway with the Manila
this was respect for the fact that the
teaching take a still if he takes ever
it takes understanding and it takes
patience the teachers who would have
done it who have been there who have
been through help students at the good
times in the bad time and it made a
difference have so much to give to women
form an education policy already in this
area behaves we be permitted in our
education when we reached out to the NEA
and it's educators and to teachers
across this country and in my pledge is
that we'll continue to do that if I'm
elected president of the United States
to make sure the missions through
testimony through equipment to important
boards that the educator societies from
ways as we move forward an education
user thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
please welcome Joe Biden
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're going to climb will have my
minutes to give an opening statements
and then we have three questions from
our members and so you need to share
with us and anything and teacher and
with three things number one teaches is
not gr but any other profession you
whole huge this is coming in your hands
it's a fact all these short order are
there are all our next addition to the
law and the dirty your hands and we now
speak a little respect or dignity we
don't know pay you enough and I heart
you
it will change around a
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
but first double the fun
where you been bringing in just a little
business of them all the people that you
need for example so disappointed in your
help because we ask too much right now
so third million I would see to it that
we heartily devoted a one hundred
million dollars 3d view to the schools
and in particularly in military crime
certainly I made sure that we understand
that one child learn the behind what to
color the razor they're back now they
all have the equal shot and that's why
we just start with universal became
it's part of an argument about all the
data is in these are probably an
evidence that it affects every single
community and the other day happy to do
with another school there's challenges
in tough neighborhoods I would hate to
significant investment on another 100
million dollars and those losses across
the country and the murder of teachers
in there to be able to get pay for
measuring being able to pay for teaching
other teachers for bringing them along
think it's just you have to happen in
schools teaching teaching teaching there
shouldn't we be doing three top
[Applause]
coming the doctor and his crew right
[Music]
the other thing is supposed we're going
to position where he had the opportunity
to fundamentally change in the schools
we're talking out the drawers or check
out the program any programs programs
that are lasted 12 years without nothing
for anybody took a little class and this
is what I call for is anyone has a
certificate degree whatever the deal is
Community College is absolutely free
[Applause]
that is proposed to have a lot of money
and if they're about to cash they become
what we need
[Applause]
we have we have a position that some
women time I didn't June who's an art
teacher in Matthew do you think as
teenagers should play in terms of
trafficking education policy local state
and national and why you should read a
policy as you saying brother duty during
Operation let's so good a plumber let's
say we got a lawyer folks you're the one
was at the moment
make sure
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Hey
[Applause]
[Music]
with regards to education usually in the
classroom should we be part of the
agenda as is what you are where you can
teach you should have to say what you
need to teach and I we began again to
position everything look look
how many you have chapters boiling water
how do you have our corners fully how
many turn on that situation so teachers
you should have the ability to have an
input and I gave you to regularize the
school the district that's a local
decision I will put a lot of pressure to
make sure T's just hang on in society
what the curriculum is what you're going
to teach them your no other person
sponsor and then lastly folks they have
you have to do the most is we have come
a teachers as the professional they are
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
what I think
[Applause]
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we are going without being high-tech
Rossiter basically don't require
on the floor very well then
but the PTAs commodities ruptures -
you're dealing with chronic acne class
and this is a big big deal but so
[ __ ] we be putting together just
obligation of accordionists to put
together people with families and it can
be done not easily be done well if you
do it another first the other thing is
we're going to position where we do my
original passive pressure and then he
country that out-educates us will
out-compete us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
please welcome Elizabeth Warren
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's also though any of our plans to
tell maybe women to put their pencils
down
so I think I'll do it 100 if we remember
the new statement and then we have three
questions for you and everybody can see
that time are all administrative and hit
a sailor we're gonna politely lab for
you okay so so good on you have one
minute to make an opening statement
[Applause]
I know what I want to do since I was in
second grade I wanted to be in a public
school either
[Applause]
by the time I graduated from high school
we didn't have money for the college
application as I said any amount of
college
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have thousands of people got up
towards honorable school videos passing
all of you questions good you're going
to hear one under the math it is from
Sarah and educational for the United
States to be sure that all the children
are entitled to a fully funded education
a quality education for all
[Applause]
you really didn't need a plan for that
so what I'm gonna give you two pieces of
it if it serves over the wealth tax
that's a two cent tax on top one-tenth
of one percent of a great fortune in
anis country being able to have more
than 50 million dollars well we say
first 250 million that's cool but and
first our picture two cents
[Applause]
it's two cents we need to provide
Universal child care for every baby in
[Applause]
for every
[Applause]
preschool teacher
[Applause]
so we have good clean tools standing in
our for all about
the universal tuition-free tagging of
the school community college and former
college
[Applause]
in a strange new sense we can connect
all of these investments plus we can
compare this to the student blog
together
[Applause]
for me this is about our valleys this is
about what we were working for you can
make it big
[Applause]
again this time to be more important
than the education of our children and
I'll tell you this about public schools
interests we recognize for the worth of
every human need we invest in the future
and we never give up
[Applause]
what a dude that guy Chewie is his
retired teacher for watching
what would you rather than a dude put an
end to high-stakes testing so that our
students and a teacher
[Applause]
so let me serve a commitment that I have
already meeting probably in fact one for
about to stage today
I made some tea senatorial education who
has been
[Applause]
see I want someone in Washington
whoever's really difficult and renews
meet anyone a ride-along regulations
it's a son line is actually the scenic
I'll light up if someone is actually
seeing someone engaged and to suddenly
look at their head no was something that
I hadn't known before someone who's seen
a door opening
[Applause]
as I said it's about our families you
know I understand that it is talking
about some of the body for all the state
capital the national capital said if
here's what constitutes success and the
word shares what constitutes Taylor no
that's not what education is about
education is what goes on in the
classroom
what like a teacher has said is the goal
and they wouldn't have it is a teacher
[Music]
[Applause]
in addition to the fundamental question
of respect for our teachers
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
your last question is for Brooke
and an elementary school teacher in the
brass when and how will you and leader
many of the possible for teachers to
earn enough to support of the set on a
teaching staff this is just a part of it
in a finished part without money but
again it's about respect and it's about
recognizing every day to work what our
teachers do here's a better place we can
start to raise teacher pay and resources
into our public schools and that is true
even our teachers unions
[Applause]
[Applause]
for how a minute negotiating
because everything you don't understand
this is it's what we need women
infinitely what we live in time but it's
also a moment you to do cancer that is
our strength
you know but we live in America what
your policy is a funder in assaulted
Washington work great for the rich you
have think a tax-free saying one
business I think exceptions they want
but for the rest of America it's just
not working we had a chance to determine
that around and that sorts with our
teachers when they were on the front
lines in West Virginia
[Applause]
not only and what teachers me just be
able to survive if it was a lesson in
democracy by saying when teachers stood
it up what kind of country do you want
to have do you have a better than bear
stripe fit in an Infanta slices at the
top or do you want to have a divorce for
all our kids teachers the front line
[Applause]
I have plans to get more money into
public education because I believe in in
public education but I understand this
is about so much more than money this is
about how we build the country we go
before this is about the value of
[Applause]
please welcome Amy Klobuchar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we we have several questions like faster
[Applause]
groups due to the escalating cost of
college quicker urban needs to do Tibet
and interprofessional image establishes
make it harder to think I got most of a
look at it what is your name
my first one is to increase teacher pay
only 3% education that's wrong and you
can hate word but anyway one of them is
questioning at the estate tax the
wealthiest the way they have an
exemption I know how that I would
encourage our state and this is a
problem for her to plan today any curves
to say you can do the same but are you
warning them for investing any teachers
this assembly thing you've got to do to
give this home in your honor to see the
moms I think you need respect for our
teachers I know this from school for a
number of years with nearly 90 percent
free and reduced lunch I just know my
daughter the public schools I was in the
public schools and I saw in everyone's
life when we didn't have that kind of
respect and those resources for teachers
so that is why I think we don't have to
fully fund our education the American
art we divided it but been fully defined
in it we have to stand up
[Applause]
cool and for the specter what I came up
with in infrastructure is about highways
and bridges incident remains and
everything but I nature of Brennan
Center was it's fine Universal
infrastructure
why because we can have friendly Souls
all over in America because we have
schools where we literally but I fear
involves torment even at have feet
so infrastructure the body a major part
of our plan for America we ever not
wanted to compete with the rest of the
world if we develop it in the best in
our schools if we know in advance in our
teachers and then if we devote and
invest in our kids the heaven is how we
recruit teachers you recruit teachers by
ITV sure I think I have the head they
can have the job environment think you
in a position or in schools is that
people who want to work and used to
support schools by supporting our
educators all over the country and that
means
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
man early in the parent cinema she were
in it and as she said how would you work
across the aisle to ensure dreamers are
getting their opportunity to attempt an
institution of higher learning pay
in-state tuition and the end of the
pathway to citizenship exactly this is
one of the saddest things what was
happening millions of kids came to the
country through no phone you know these
kids they are nearly every school in
America has one of these kids so what I
thinking that we need to do is put
another mile on a path to citizenship to
make them insecure because it's kind of
oh we tried just recently when the
determinant is a person by the way what
I do when I'm in this is making sure we
don't have any
[Applause]
[Applause]
we have came from other kind of things
25% of our us ores were born in other
countries many of these kids they may
not even know the language I think they
come to your school their parents don't
know any what who set up right you you
do and you know put them on a path where
they are economy and in the world so I
want to thank you for that Bosnia and
out her I will make sure that these kids
are heard of America
and then you are rewarded for that work
[Applause]
[Music]
question this one comes from James an
educator from Illinois
Anthony what would you do to renovate
the decaying infrastructure it is some
of our country's public schools
Thanks so what happening right now this
president
he claimed on election night I don't
know if any of you remember that night
it was a pretty depressing evening
well he said it that night maybe he
wanted to invest in this country right
he said it better when it's the
presidency because everyone wants to
invest in infrastructure what has he
done right no he called over the leaders
and Democratic Party speaker Pelosi
calls over the White House claims he
wants to do something they come back in
any local media for everything there's
been no investment and a major change in
any band in infrastructure that's why
I'm seeing these schools I chose some of
the schools my daughter was in it I seen
in the tools with anyone recently and
I've seen these goals where kids can't
play because there's no places to play
and I think schools like the probable
school for high school which was I think
about 60 percent free and reduced lunch
somewhere around there second caller
they invested in that school and I
and home of those teachers when they
went to work every day kind of the main
hallway within modern and equipment
within modern computer equipment I was
able to see the difference firsthand and
senior kidded that the public schools
you can't close your eyes to the need
for infrastructure and the need to
support our teachers and the need to
have a major part going forward so I
just want to end by thanking you for
your work like I said I would not be
here today without teachers my mom
wanted to teach her everything she come
on everybody unit we came up with her
severely disabled son she said that is
my son here Monica second grade when he
graduated he got a job packing groceries
and every year your mom would come back
after she finished Saturday releasing
the mother play standing in line and
give a big hug
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
maybe when is botanist so grateful to be
with so many educators here today miss
Texas to my friends especially one of
the neighborhoods that the great huge
Jackson Lee represents of Congress its
Kashmir parts a neighborhood that has
been hit by three five hundred year laws
in just the last five years hurricane
party
Judith Allison and instead of his team
was of the wursten we should enough to
that neighborhood time after time and
one year to the day we saw four of the
five libraries down we passed a cashmere
elementary and said this is tough school
but this is the right spot the
neighborhood if every child the Boston
knows the he or she this is the right
place because they get to be educators
children
[Applause]
and you stand or whatever
yes and we have a great point of silence
at 32,000 tons because I love it strong
public schools to ensure that in my
students and in their community anymore
anything one let's together Allison
thanks for the amazing what you just
asked it perhaps picking up on capture
card supplementary those children of
parents who are addicted to opioids who
have lived through so much trauma and
suffering which counted histories when
they identify that teacher to do
everything within her power within his
power to make sure that is all knowledge
is providing world class instruction but
so often out of her own pocket paying
for the supplies for that child paying
for that a meal there on the free and
reduced revenues and lunch does not make
a war on healed over them to look
forward to at the end of the day that
teachers can provide a meal shows up day
after day in the same hair jeans
the same t-shirt say notice she's a new
set of clothes no only this ability to
learn is tied to the dignity and to his
self-worth
so those teachers make sure they're
there those
we're struggling in households that are
written by addiction and opioid abuse on
make sure that we've got their mass and
that means it's all leading the
pharmaceutical corporations that have
participation accountable for what have
done about justice or accountability
community and there's an overdose that
we saw last year long term and those
teachers those educators struggling
under these conditions providing that
wraparound care for every child
entrusted with it either here I want to
make sure that they can focus on and the
second is for a third episode need to do
that means the right to organize for
every educator and every single state
[Applause]
these jobs just to make it that easily
you forgive your stupid long dad if you
dedicate your life
[Applause]
and it means that we invest in HBCUs
[Music]
to be sure that this teachers and
educators in those classrooms
[Applause]
[Music]
right in this question is James a 77282
in California
[Applause]
- no what are you done to support unions
today's from California thank you for
the question we've seen the devastation
in our communities and in our seis when
you are not allowed to organize justice
in Iowa over the fourth of July and
learn from those great educators in Iowa
that after 2017 when the state
legislature is true their rights to
organize their ability to use the
letters of the value that they provide
public education no longer be able to
organize expecially for higher wages
better working positions in the delivery
of care and destruction to children
those teachers and educators are leaving
Iowa Minnesota the density of the
physicists eaters and chemistry teachers
and in kindergarten teachers paid for by
the taxpayers of a violin so as
president I want to make sure that we
need eternity the right to organize for
every educator and observer in the right
here
[Applause]
I wanna make sure that I follow the lead
that unions obsessed to keep Aaron Skeen
to take time off to suspend that with
the Turner family wiki and pay that this
child care is affordable in every single
part of this country without regard to
remain calm
or your city code that we have pre-k
universal lifetime insurances and
children and the net welfare is not a
function of a privilege or luck or
circumstances but as a base from the
right every single child believe these
seen in corporations and seen in people
and communities and neighborhoods when
we do that this is economy in our
country will truly work for every single
one of us and every summer to see a
future for themselves which means this
is a pharmacy
United States of America continue to
have a future at the richest country on
the face of the bland
[Applause]
[Music]
I can finish this is the last a lot and
the Irish
we have a question for every Cynthiana
I love my teacher from Washington she
asked
[Applause]
fools announcers and whatever you wanted
to do may be sure to pop up their
education funding
it's a certain we use for public
education so the city and I are the
parents of twelve-year-old boy Lucy's is
Molly just turned 11 and he was eight
years old
and they all go to world class dual
language public schools education so I
wanna be clear in the way we walk the
talk that I believe is in public schools
and public education in my
administration
I wanted to romantically increase the
funding for public education for example
paying the full frame of the federal
obligation for ID
[Applause]
[Music]
bernetta clothes for public education
500 billion dollars that will be
invested to a leading and the release of
the society between minority majority
schools and school districts we're gonna
be sure that we invest in an educator
training so national certification our
administration
and we will ensure they send the master
teacher program so that those who
invested so much of their lives in
service to this country through those
children base and those schools can also
teach the next generation of educators
and I will tell you this not only do i
as a Democrat I don't only you
understand not a single design of our
public adjusters
[Music]
[Applause]
small town in Texas Henrietta Texas
listening to every local teacher she
believed better if you let us take my
public tax dollars turn them into ride
to school I will find you and I will
hold you accountable which tells me that
the Republican and independent or
Democrat all lead any public schools
there is a place for Republic nonprofit
charter schools but the providers
charter schools and about your programs
the city will die my administration
group to them we will fully fund public
education and public educators and to
make sure we have a public education in
the United States of America we are
going to have your back
[Applause]
we have ready for the next Saturday
please welcome Jay
[Applause]
but they may have three questions for
you and we give it three minutes and it
is a little tight
[Applause]
my name is Liana governor in state of
Washington and personally the product of
educators and possibly the product the
educational community I hang the sign of
frankly a bottle of that the brother
Freddie can lead brother of a Bonnington
Seville India he's wouldn't after and
different my heard to this
they have so many thousands of lies
I know teachers in in theater to another
state and I know this time that
president where education is a family
affair that this is a family affair for
me and the matters minecraft tell you
the district evenness to devotion I mean
we would say the distill teachers I'm
telling you that I don't government
shiver because the biggest teacher pay
increase in the United States
[Applause]
video from Georgia but the question
about because the fundamental anyway you
can have all the answers and only you
could have had but a reunions anonymous
kill really stores energy here to
provide relationship with people
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a we we have the reverses the
Detroit asked us when we take the
ability to motivate for the oil and gas
industry we put it in in education by
so you've benefited from an accident to
rural communities so we wouldn't you do
this and I think this is important we
need a man to carry that's as much about
the career aspirations
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
coming up in there Elizabeth is
noticeably higher education instructor
and she wants to know how do we get guns
out of schools and make schools safe for
children and staff
[Applause]
[Music]
we are across the heart saying that your
students have endure this shout out of
fear cover the school we are saying you
have to dedicate yourself and helping
their students through this anxiety when
you should be hoping them whether their
curriculum in the new think what we need
is president who has the ability to
stand up on these decisions become a
safety I'll start there
we need someone who will stand up to be
BR a story 1994 in the 90 to 94 hours as
a freshman congressman from a small town
of Sela in a rented building
agricultural district in eastern
Washington and there is a vanilla camera
that proposed to be have strong efforts
either there had a great advance for my
seat in this rural agricultural district
[Music]
[Applause]
and now now having lost my disease I'm
governor distinguish when he have been
asked forgetting each other the ones
that education association for that you
very much
and the Talia passed through any major
investigation of legislation we have any
array on Anne Arundel run to the state
it is time to happen there only were
running in Washington DC
[Applause]
[Music]
we didn't know that is the only issue
down the bubble Cruz is wrong - he says
if it's illusion that this is just
keeping further training teachers and
Glock pistols I reach to the White House
has to be ready for them
you're gonna just belong it has to any
idea you need if we between communities
[Applause]
we need
we need more counselors to repeal soon
[Applause]
the land owners business whether they're
exposed to the problems of ocarina and
the Bible you need to do this when high
standard together on the an educator I
included educators but I swear
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
this one comes from Marty she's a
special education teacher at Kansas
[Applause]
research fact that the early education
is a great medicine how do you finance
high quality public early education
programs for every child in 1989 and we
came up with this van have Olivia get
any 384 old students having the early
college education
so the think you ready for bikini car so
that the kid is getting ready for first
grade at that time it was as radical
because there's really good wonderful
information about effectiveness that and
I prefer to think all the children
initiative it's as finance that we did
you not to have that but now every later
when you know the neurological evidence
that this is perhaps the same the best
medicine of a boggart activity in the
United States we understand this for now
I'm pleased kind of these governors in
Washington we did not anomaly and
achieved
fully Native American student
[Applause]
[Music]
- I'm gonna be able to say what is
justified veneration it reminds maybe we
needed mercy when the bombs from Canada
for understand if I have prohibited
policies he forgot me so that refugees
from a state senator we believe
[Applause]
just a minute you a deputy to
professionalize to the generations of
the company - and we need have the who
we have a world addition to those
generations but move along addition to
defeat the plan of crisis
I've dedicated a way to defeat a crisis
I never proposed the plan to make sure
we could work
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome Bill DeBlasio
[Applause]
real quick we're going to give you a
minute to give an opening statement and
then we're going to ask you three times
a standardized test the answer is C
[Music]
yes and see the tiny little clapping
yeah they can see it up there and when
it gets down to zero we're very nice
we're just gonna clamp for you until you
stop okay
please one minute
thank you everybody
all right everyone I'm gonna be
bothering you I am angry about to say
the public entities in America I'm angry
about the fact that you are
disrespecting a remember business in
this country despite who interests
important work I'm angry about the
private attackers saying hey our
teachers to not you I hate the private
time so I wanna stop them
I'm thinking from the federal government
that does not focus or invest an
education and it doesn't have to be
either that way
and every time they're supposed to we we
talk about money to say there's a
foreign country it is just in the wrong
hands
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and our another website I've even
divided in folks to submit questions
from all over the country this is a
video that one of our members uploaded
this is from Stephanie and Ohio she has
this video question
[Applause]
[Music]
the federal government is not working in
an apologist country we need a federal
government responsibility for education
in this country from charter schools no
funding for articles
[Applause]
the way schools
[Applause]
[Applause]
wanna make sure that we get away from
saying we need a secretary education
who's gonna be something very very
different about erratically anywhere the
next secretary
largest school systems in the country
and then I said when I did there's no
way in hell I'm naming anyone career
educator to those Patrol
[Applause]
and it was
indicators and acquitted Cobb
rejuvenated that has to if we lose our
schools and true true
[Applause]
okay right in to that website Christina
a teacher from Minnesota at
[Applause]
[Applause]
it is you believe public education is
right and then the foundation of our
democracy
how do you plan to support that after so
many years of neglect public education
is a right and is the foundation of our
society is thinking we change things
what I'm planning to make the federal
government is truly responsible for
finally public schools remember in a
country where so much of the
responsibility falls on the localities
that can not afford the money this is a
collar bearer of the rust as a system
there's no federal mandate there's no
Commission speed up it is not about how
to really the best education for our
children
that's not we today it is whatever
happily with some panel systems give
your luck the educational
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the wrong way so here's the second thing
I said her early style education should
we need to know the register to reach
occasions between birdie result but many
flowers to the discus tree full of
desire to top six what we're doing
backwards
we we
[Applause]
stop there in there I thought we should
see those estate for three-year-olds
time to talk a lot of the Buccaneers
today we understand it through que falta
de Education spree international plan
for a 3d cake from Jorge and repeated on
every school in America and an f-35
[Applause]
lastly I'm gonna propose something that
may sound really big but as this country
[Applause]
[Applause]
our next member is Trisha she's a
teacher librarian from Illinois
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but the question is masters who has done
the fishin talking about had done in Ely
or in a place we invested constantly by
the way when you're not only the
disability we invested in our evidence
every year that I've given a range
[Applause]
[Applause]
and the ages and messages came off and
the disappoint you have to be another
chance in ancient times touches in
America it is a chance to say it wrong
and occasionally to get it right but it
has to be the responsibility it's a
chance to say the least
we need to define working people and
educators are working people
[Applause]
every tribe there's a start at the same
starting line it isn't that we believe
it
[Applause]
it wasn't the big history beginning you
talk about it was inspired me well
enough maybe because it destroyed her
what's mine was to the other networks -
as a nation that massive public
education of the right way it can be
done as I said there's plenty of money
it's just in the wrong hands
[Applause]
[Music]
we already have it please love them too
right
[Music]
[Applause]
do a little even illy what together
wouldn't you say they see this little
kid clock here they didn't see it like
one on the screen so that all you have
to do if you if you go over
we're very sweet we're going to just
start clicking for you we're so nice and
then we have three questions we'd like
to give you three minutes to answer so
welcome you can sit it maybe this Dan
and you can just be coming for Bowl
thank you
hi
everyone was telling us how good things
are and I just wonder why we all feel so
bad why we wake up in the morning and
got a hot nurse I like turn on TV we see
what's happenin every day and the
reality is for 40 years the citizens in
the United States have been broken our
economic system has been broken the
education system is broken in the health
care system in the foods that has been
broken the environmental systems have
been broken the criminal justice system
and all of these issues make their way
in interiors school and so today's
discussion is about our reform education
but we transform
[Applause]
[Music]
video questions for the beginning we
have a video question for you from
sanity in Pennsylvania if you get
elected how would you help with funding
we have learning and haha food is
Finnerty so that I believe everyone to
come on
thank you actually a great question I
really should say a plan this week that
inputs 50 DB moving in the bothers back
into funny the line and your other
programs to local communities schools
and their school programming that they
[Music]
were a hundred million dollars
infrastructure projects and it schools
all across in the United States of
America and you know better than anybody
we can have a twenty three million
dollar gap between the wealthiest school
districts in the country and school
districts that have high populations of
the partying too little color and I
think it's imperative and even close to
that gap and it maybe isn't of essence I
think we can help these fools
rebuild I think we hope like Ronnie and
I think we know that the playgrounds
school-based health clinics we make sure
that every school has a makerspace so we
can move ourselves into the 21st
these issues that are critically
important I also have on our plan my
plan a moment we giving this program for
teachers and also an expanded tax credit
for teachers digging into their own
pocket and pay a lot of money
and I know it because my wife is a
person a schoolteacher
I would say also we need an economic
plan in the States of America that
really builds the middle classes in the
United States of America for her to live
in we even hit the mind healthy very
feasible accountable who have run away
with all of the bowl just like you old
country song you know you hit the gold
mine we get the shaft it is time for us
of a hole that has broken the economic
status of the McConnell they didn't
convince people in the United States
then we cut to access or so they're the
top one percent that it somehow that
builds our school somehow them to be
able to have hire new teachers somehow
the hospital provide health care we're
not just talking about education and in
this honor today we're talking about
reshipping in the priorities of the
United States of America from the top
one percent the work
[Music]
a penguin combines a working-class I
need white black brown beige straight
more south urban rural all of us 30
years whose branches of Democrats in the
Union Union
[Applause]
vinicky is an editor for a great state
of Hawaii and she
and wants to know your plan to observe
the sky violence and it's top of the
proliferation of school shootings that's
a great question
this is obviously they're very personal
my way that's a school teacher as I
mentioned it right down the hall our
five-year-old Brady those depreciable
and like all of you who also have kids
tools mirror obviously in schools all
the other kids here this is an issue
that we see too often and in this
community to the United States and its
allies support the universal background
check I am sure we can get weapons of
the war the treaties of the United
States America
nice before what we closed in Charleston
loophole for studying about violence and
is a public health issue in the United
States
[Applause]
but I also believe that we have to play
honest and in my plan we have a program
the wraparound services to make sure
that we have a mental health counselor
and every school in the United States of
America
[Music]
that we can have a nurse energy school
but here's what I think the most
important 90% of kids who come to a
school and users come on and until
students and other educators 90% of
those from high school and it's a 73% of
those is that the felt shame or Louie or
isolated in some way and I lead this is
imperative for us to Castle and
emotional learning and every school so
the weekend is we can make sure that all
of these pieces are connected to each
other through the teacher to the school
which is why the same hook had there's
terrible tragedy they went off and they
did an analysis of a hobby can we
prevent this from happening again in the
United States and it's Carla Lewis dear
friend of mine who was one of the
parents who lost kid with a just
analysis together they came back with
three repetitions ones and I'll punish
twos to control and in three is social
emotional learning and his Souls God
help you God if we're gonna transform
our schools we have to start recognizing
and then before you doing anything
before you start talking about tests
we've got the first part again about how
take care of our commercials
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so kinda the rules
[Applause]
great teachers have a lot of kids didn't
follow the rules
maybe one more question for you and then
this one economist River Barbara she's a
retired educator from the great state of
Oregon and her question is what would
you do in transit to ensure retired
educators pensions and Benevento still
be protected from their kitchen
[Applause]
[Music]
first avenues would reveal the windfall
elimination provision
[Applause]
government offset provision I thought
you should just sit down thinking better
than women a try
but I will say that that is an essential
issue that I'd be dealing with a long
time representing Ohio it is critical to
make sure that you go out or not respond
so we really don't care
[Applause]
but you also have to record security
after we do that and I have a plan
security security so pointing 100 I want
to make sure that we pull over 13
million citizens in this country who
need a pay raise I want to make sure
that this is the dispersion or is an
hour I talk about the economy and growth
and even exhaust that the helps us avoid
the local taxes so the belief in
increase wages teachers so you come on
negotiate contracts put more money into
your retirement
it's to me that means you've got the
bubble the size the unions in the United
States of America
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I just went in I just want to end
with a quick story about Mohammed Ali
Mohammed Ali there's a great story in
someone's kitchen of Muhammad Ali into
Kentucky when the neighbor is tired and
he went up at the Mohammed Halloween
he's dead hey champ I saw anybody
neither knows champ had a little hybrid
great and they said yes I you got
knocked down into the third round and he
said the guy said I remember my dad put
me he took the body and when you saw me
was a pretty fight but could give a
compound in the third round and an ollie
said what wasn't my fight I ain't never
been knocked down chances that um either
up or I'm out
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
a candidate is generally
[Applause]
please welcome
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for a minute okay one minute to make any
opening statement and three minutes and
women clock lines down just keep going
we're gonna love you so much that we're
just gonna start clapping redundant
clapping and so we would start and you
can stand you can be comfortable one
minute for your own extinct okay
greetings everyone
I want to thank you for what you do
every day our educators our edges you
were amazing
you and I which is the first in the
nation is ministry in closing the
teacher can you have
although
[Applause]
here and we will close it by the federal
embezzlement you can totally imagine
final in the state because here's my
believing that it is strongly I believe
based on how it is Sean
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we didn't buy all of our clear alien
members and really anyone in the public
to upload a question hello to video or
rank question what we have over you is
our first question okay and it is they
moved it so bad I didn't get to see who
is bro
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
because whose meaning man
- are falling through the cracks and it
is immoral it is wrong
[Applause]
slowly they need situation we need to
know and that began has children with
these meetings we need to know that and
we have the system in place for
assessing that floor would be it's been
there but we still are not meeting their
needs
it is wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
riding it on our website is Susan a
retired teacher from Minnesota and she
asked
what questions will you ask with hitting
your Department of Education Center
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but I will say this in all seriousness
that is one of probably the most
important positions in the president's
half a minute it is the position that is
it is charged with a new meeting to
concern itself the future of our nation
to concern itself with the future of my
children to concern yourself with where
we are what we are supporting them and
whether we are challenged you man
whether we are eliminating that mob and
we all know that the Harris
administration I prize you that the
person who is nominated
[Applause]
right to that you will be at the table
doesn't help me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here our position will be what under the
polls is important important tasks to do
the right way
[Applause]
[Music]
let's make it multiple choice
our last question comes from one of our
higher education members Sally is a
psychology professor she wants to know
what will you do to ensure students are
treated fairly by companies
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]